chancellor angela merkel has voiced her
frustration over the way
germany's local authorities are handling
the pandemic
she's now threatened to resort to
federal powers
reporting from berlin his rt's peter
oliver
well during this interview that the
chancellor gave on sunday evening she
looked particularly sick and tired
and bumping heads with local leaders she
described some of the leaders of
germany's states as
being not free from illusions that they
could actually negotiate
with the covert 19 virus we are
set to see some local restrictions put
in place here in berlin
this week on wednesday or from wednesday
ffp2 masks will be required
they're more heavy duty masks in shops
and on public transport
we're also going to see more testing put
in place particularly for things like
getting a haircut but this all comes as
intensive care doctors in germany are
saying the country
actually needs a nationwide tough
two-week lockdown that's something
that's being backed up by angela
merkel's health minister
yen spahn when we decided if we look at
the numbers we need another 10 to 14
days at least
of properly driving down contacts and
movements a lockdown if you want to call
it that
well germany's currently hovering at
around the 20 000
new cases of covert 19 a day mark the
warning
that's coming out is that that could
rise during this
third wave that's got its hands on
europe to as much as 100
000 per day the indications clearly
point
to this wave potentially being even
worse than the first two waves
we must be prepared for a steep rise in
the number of cases
for more people to once again become
seriously ill that hospitals will be
overburdened and that more people will
die
again if this continues unchecked we run
the risk that our healthcare system will
reach its breaking point in
april when it comes to vaccinations the
plan remains that all adults will be
offered a job by the end of september
that's a plan that looks particularly
ambitious right now
when you take into account that not all
of the over 80s in germany
have had one jab yet when it comes to
vaccination
though local leaders are saying they
want russia's sputnik v
vaccine to get approval so that can be
used in the fight against covert
the approval of sputnik v must be
decided as soon as possible
i'm fighting for sputnik v not just
because it's been produced in russia
i believe that we should buy all
vaccines which are available it has
nothing to do with party politics or a
proximity to moscow
i find west german ideological
sensitivities on this question
silly supply issues as well as
investigations into the safety of
vaccines have seen
the vaccination program in europe be
glacially slow
thierry breton the eu commissioner in
charge of the vaccine program
has said that getting russia's sputnik v
vaccine online
wouldn't be a magic bullet that would
fix all of europe's problems
if the vaccine is certified within weeks
or months and a way is found to produce
it in europe
it would take at least 10 to 14 months
before the first batch is manufactured
but it will not be a response to our
problems today
with vaccination levels not being as
high as they are in other parts of the
world
europe is staring down the barrel of
more lockdowns
more restrictions on its citizens
you